hey guys Pete here this will be my
better call Saul season 5 episode 7
recap and review I feel like a broken
record but as a fan I have to call him
like I see him and this was another
great episode the thing that's always
impressed me about better call Saul is
how they've been able to take a story
that we basically know the end of and
take us on a journey that we couldn't
have expected when I first heard they
would be making a prequel show about
Walter White's lawyer who more or less
felt like comic relief it was hard to
imagine how they could cook up anything
that might be as gripping as the
original watching Jimmy deliver his
lightning bolt shoot from my fingertips
feels equal to Walters I'm the one who
knocks speech and I feel that's really a
surprise that I'm here for episode 7 is
titled JMM which is Jimmy's initials
James Morgan McGill when Lalo asked him
about them later he uses the line he
came up with when he was talking to Kim
justice matters most and things fall
perfectly into place when Lalo suggested
instead just make money for the saw we
knew and Breaking Bad that would make
perfect sense but as we watch this
episode unfold we see there's still a
lot of Jimmy McGill under the surface
before we talk about that I want to talk
about gusts because his part of the
episode was better than usual I would
say and it drove something home for me I
do a trailer breakdown each week and in
the comments of the last one a lot of
people jumped in saying they thought
this shot of Gus was related to Madrigal
electro-motive and a Lydia appearance in
my mind I was like yeah that's probably
the case you know cool but how is that
really an important part of things based
on everything else that's going on well
I'll tell you how bring back another
Breaking Bad character Peter Schuler who
had a memorable 5 minute arc in the
teaser for episode 2 of season 5 hair
Schuler was the head of madrigals fast
food division we meet him as he
dispassionately tastes new dipping
sauces until he's interrupted by his
assistant who lets him know the police
are in his office waiting for him we
watch this story come to an end in that
same dispassionate manner but here we
get to see a different side of him after
a meeting at madrigals Houston office
we watched Gus
go back to his hotel and witness an
amazing little sequence where he settles
in and he's getting ready for something
I loved watching hear how he does
everything so precisely how it's all
such a controlled situation he goes to
meet with Lydia and Peter in their
joining room and they ask him about this
Lalo situation
Gus admits that even though Lola's
locked up he's still a threat
Lydia suggests that maybe he should get
stabbed basically a prison shanking
which is another reference to an event
we see happen in Breaking Bad but Gus
explains that he can't really do
anything because if anything happens to
Lalo on this side of the border then the
cartel will think he's behind it
the most interesting thing here is that
Gus is able to calm him down by talking
about what happened in Santiago of
course we want to know more about his
history we've heard chalet mentioned a
couple of different times now and I'm
hoping that this means that we're gonna
get some real answers as things stand
Gus has to burn down one of his own
restaurants because he needs to protect
nacho who he's got playing both sides
this involves a really great trigger
device where he uses a whole frozen
chicken he turns on that same fryer that
we saw Lyle laboring over and the other
great Gus sequence of this season and he
leaves things set up so that it'll slide
in and start the fire after he exits the
building it's pretty badass all the way
around watching him walk away as the
thing goes up in flames from there let's
go back and talk about Jimmy and Kim at
the end of the last episode Kim had
proposed this idea of marriage and in
this episode they get right down to it
we see them having a conversation
talking about the details and this is
where it all makes sense this is the
same kind of situation where people have
been saying the reason that she wanted
to get married was to protect herself
from having to testify against Saul in
case he got in trouble that in and of
itself didn't sound like a very
interesting reason but as we see her
explain that she just wants to know what
he's doing we actually see that it
serves multiple purposes basically what
we see here is a mirroring of that
situation where we saw them in the park
King LA the next morning after throwing
the beer bottles Kim sees this as an
opportunity to have an honest
relationship she says to Jimmy she
doesn't want to be in the dark anymore
if he feels like he has the urge not to
tell her what he's doing in his business
then that's a good time that he'd better
tell her and now that all makes sense
right because while it is a legal
solution it's also Kim's way of fixing
this problem where she can't be taken by
surprise she can't be scammed by her
partner if they're being fully
transparent with each other it's great
how this all plays out because we see
Jimmy telling Huell that it's just this
technicality for legal reasons so they
go through the motions we do learn that
he has been divorced twice already the
woman at the counter asked for his
paperwork on his previous to
disillusions we knew one for sure but
there's always been this question of how
he was married and divorced twice it's
led some people to thinking that Kim
might have been his second wife in his
second divorce but as we watch this
through a fantastic performance by both
Bob Odenkirk and Rhea seehorn we see
that they're telling themselves one
thing but there's a lot of other stuff
going on as well the whole thing happens
really fast
Kim has made the decision that this is a
choice to protect herself but as they
take these awkward bowels we see that it
becomes something more it's not just a
marriage of convenience but this is
something that they're entering into
together it was played really well and
it comes off and I'm surprised at how
much I could enjoy this based on the
reason that they went into this idea
it's worth mentioning the pivotal role
that Huell plays here and that's all
topped off with his taking the instant
photo of them at the end of course they
both have busy days planned Jimmy gets
the call that he has to go meet his new
client jorge de guzman who was actually
Lalo it's not a big surprise that the
judge would deny bail and Jimmy thinks
that they should probably try to look at
a deal Lalo brings up this idea of does
he want to be a friend of the cartel
which initially seems kind of irrelevant
because there's no way that he could get
him out of this and with that we leave
it there Kim heads over to Mesa
trying to clean up the mess that Jimmy
has caused with his Saul Goodman antics
at the previous day's meeting they make
their case and Kevin doesn't seem moved
and on the way out he makes a comment
about Jimmy which it was kind of hard to
figure out where things were gonna go
from there
when she comes back in the room I almost
expected her to blow up about that but
instead she makes a pretty effective
move and telling Kevin you know what
it's your fault we're your lawyers we
advised you to do the right thing you
chose to do your own thing and this is
where we ended up in the end that works
because he tells them that they'll see
them on Thursday which means that he's
willing to put the situation behind them
when the couple get back together at
home we see their non honeymoon things
get heated up we almost get a sex scene
and then Jimmy has to stop things in
order to tell her about what happened
today and Lalo's offer of being a friend
to the cartel this is something that
he's kept from her and now he's doing
what she wants he's telling her honestly
what's going on
and at this point he's still able to say
it doesn't matter because I can't do it
I'm not going to be able to get this guy
bail and in a weird way this is sort of
like the actual consummation of their
marriage he's honest about something he
doesn't want to be and from there they
can move on with him doing what she
asked him to do nacho makes an
appearance we saw him get the call from
Lalo who told him that he wanted him to
burn down one of the restaurants he
asked Mike for help we learned that he
put nacho back in charge and that he
wants out but he can't do anything until
he takes care of this situation with his
father Mike is doing better we see him
with Kayleigh and Stacey
he tells Stacey that he's decided to
play the cards that he's dealt which
explains to us how he got to where he's
at it wasn't so much that he sees
something in Gus that he wants to move
forward with but he's decided to move
ahead just the same because at least
this way he has some control over what's
going on Gus having found that Lalo
being in jail is actually worse than him
being out sends Mike to give Jimmy the
information he'll need to get Lalo out
Jimmy asked him
who he's working for which Mike doesn't
want to tell him and there's still a
little bit of confusion about that
because it doesn't seem like in the
Breaking Bad timeline that Saul knows
that much about what Mike does either
way the information that he gives him is
enough for Jimmy and this whole sequence
in the courtroom is something to watch
the family of the victims are there and
Jimmy like you could see it that he's
really having a hard time with this but
at the same time he snaps right into
form and says exactly what he needs to
say to get this bail set up it really
shows both sides of him and how fluidly
he moves back and forth we see it play
out to his conclusion outside the
courtroom we see Jimmy in this great
shot where he's sneaking around the
corner to look at the victims family we
see half of him and the reflection and
it doesn't quite make the whole you know
we know he doesn't feel good about what
he just did and then Howard comes up to
be the catalyst for this breakdown that
we see we find out that Howard's going
to pull the offer he knows Jimmy threw
the bowling balls he knows about the
prostitutes Jimmy tries to deny it at
first but then he completely loses it
when Howard says that he knows he's in
pain he fires back saying that Howard
killed Chuck you see this massive amount
of projection coming from him everything
that he can't face he sees this guy in
front of him he puts it on him and he
just starts talking madness he thinks
that the job is beneath him he has no
idea what he's capable of and it's also
sad as much as that is exciting because
we know that Saul is this guy who drives
around in a white Cadillac wearing
ridiculous suits and operates out of a
strip mall with an inflatable Statue of
Liberty on top of his office well he is
good at doing the things he does we
can't imagine that that really satisfies
him in the sense that he's talking about
it here he's got a massive inferiority
complex
he must on some level realize that he
has a big role in his brother's death
and we see that this hatred that he has
for Howard is just a result of pushing
all that stuff
and wow he says I travel in worlds you
can't even imagine you can't conceive of
what I'm capable of I'm so far beyond
you I'm like a god in human clothing
lightning bolts shoot from my fingertips
and it's funny because if you've been
following this show like I have and you
go and read it in different places you
know there's always been these
conversations about this is the moment
when Jimmy becomes Saul obviously we've
learned over these last five seasons
that isn't something that happens at one
moment but I think here we get a really
good idea of where it all comes from if
nothing else the contrasts are
fascinating between how Jimmy deals with
his stuff Kim deals with her stuff and
we see Howard dealing with his Kim's got
this problem with the relationship so
she thinks of this solution she's got
this problem with Mesa Verde so she
faces that head-on and she fixes it
Jimmy tries to end around everything
including his brother's death and it
explodes and we see that Howard is
actually dealing with that same thing on
the other end and getting through it in
a healthy fashion and like I said I
think this is a great episode it gives
us deeper insight to Kim and what she's
thinking why she makes the decisions
that she makes the Gus stuff was
interesting and added a little more
depth to his story and of course here we
are with Jimmy shouting at the
courthouse making a giant scene thinking
that he's got it all figured out so yeah
this was a recurring theme in this
episode for me as a fan things that I
didn't think that would have that much
impact turned out to be really good
underlying reasons for the decisions
that the characters made as I said I
feel like a broken record saying it but
jeez what a good episode but let me know
what you think let me know in the
comments what you thought of this
episode what you thought about the
wedding between Jimmy and Kim where do
you think things are heading I know next
episode is called bagman and Vince
Gilligan will be directing that he said
it's one of the most difficult things he
ever did that's pretty exciting I'll be
doing a trailer breakdown in a couple of
days so make sure you check back for
that please like this video if you
enjoyed it
please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching I will talk
to you soon